[Music]
well i felt like canceling uh feminists
again today one of my favorite pastimes
and initially i thought i'd cancel them
for this according to espn quote
players from the united states women's
national team have settled their law
their class action equal pay lawsuit
against the u.s soccer federation for a
total of 24 million dollars the ussf has
also committed to providing an equal
rate of pay going forward for the
women's and men's national teams in all
friendlies and tournaments including the
world cup the issue of world cup bonuses
had long been a point of contention uh
for the players quote from uh megan
rapido she says there's no real justice
in this other than this never happening
again with the settlement of the working
conditions and this settlement which is
contingent upon a cba that will have
equal pay going forward there's no other
way to look at it than just a monumental
win for women's sports and women's
soccer in particular
okay so female soccer players will now
get equal pay
something that if they didn't have it
before it was probably because
nobody cares about women's soccer
it's a simple economic explanation it's
the same thing that explains why wnba
players make three dollars an hour while
nba players make three million dollars
an hour i might be slightly exaggerating
the pay scales there but the point is
that the nba has lots of fans whether it
should or not while nobody has ever
actually seen a wnba game like nobody
has
there's actually a lively philosophical
debate about whether or not the wnba
even technically exists
given how little interest there is in it
women's soccer for its part has two
strikes against it one soccer two
women's
although i suppose i should be grateful
that female athletes have finally
achieved equal pay
right in time for the men to take over
and that really is the greatest
absurdity here
because these liberal female athletes
are celebrating this great victory for
women's sports even as women's sports
has effectively ceased to exist
and that's i think worthy of its own
cancellation if not for this at the 11th
hour
the women's march has swooped in to
claim the cancelled title for itself
playing the gender card on a different
topic but just as absurdly the women's
march official account on twitter
tweeted this quote
women hold 929 billion dollars in
student debt two-thirds of the nation's
entire 1.7 trillion dollar student debt
load
this is a gender justice issue
potus cancels student debt and put an
end to this crisis
okay
where to begin
first of all
929 billion is not two-thirds of 1.7
trillion it's a little more than half
about 55 percent give or take which is
considerably less than two-thirds
if women are having trouble getting into
college i think we just discovered why
except in fact they aren't having
trouble getting into college women get
into college more often than men they
account for almost 60 percent of
university enrollment if they also have
the lion's share of debt that would
explain why
more women in college equals more women
with college debt pretty logical
but
60 enrollment against 55 of debt
actually means that each individual
woman on average is carrying less of the
debt burden than each individual man
men are the ones paying more than their
fair share if that's how you want to
look at it although it's not how you
ought to look at it because the only
share that each should pay is the share
they agreed to pay when they willingly
took out their loans
does that make it a fair share
probably not
i mean not fair in any kind of
objectively ethical sense
the fact is that most people agree to
pay way too much for an education that's
worth way too little
if you spent six figures on a degree
in a queer art history or whatever
thinking that it would somehow pay
itself back in five years given the
overwhelming market demand for queer art
historians i can't say that you paid a
fair price price
the fair price would have been zero
dollars
which is quite a bit less than
what you're on the hook for
but it's still your debt
it isn't anybody else's it's yours
so all this talk about relief and
forgiveness it obscures the point the
government cannot snap its mighty
fingers and make the debt go away that's
not going to happen
no plan has been presented that would
that would or could accomplish such a
thing
somebody has to pay your debts
the debt you agreed to
while purchasing the product you wanted
and will keep
has to be paid
the only question is this who should pay
it you or someone else
i don't see how you could offer any
sound argument for the latter even if
you can convince me that the debt is
unfair and predatory and you were taken
advantage of
i might agree with all of that but it
still seems clear that the fairest of
the unfair remedies is for the person
who took out the loan to pay it
because if it's unfair that you have to
pay your loans it's certainly many times
more unfair that i should have to pay
your loans or anybody else
besides whatever possible argument could
be made for loan forgiveness
would clearly apply just as much to any
other form of debt mortgage car credit
card etc
if you're struggling with student debt
and you're handed a get out of jail free
card and i didn't go to college but i'm
struggling to pay my mortgage
should i not be offered the same deal
if your debt is a public emergency why
isn't my debt also a public emergency
now it's true that i can file for
bankruptcy but bankruptcy isn't free and
it ain't fun
and i'm probably gonna lose a lot of my
stuff in the process you don't have to
declare bankruptcy under any student
loan forgiveness plan i've seen
why should i have to take that step what
makes you special
what happened to equality under the law
in fact
you know i really can't take any loan
forgiveness plan seriously that doesn't
require at a minimum
the college grad who wants forgiveness
must declare bankruptcy
and also forfeit their college degree
nobody can take away what they learned
especially because most of them didn't
learn anything
but the degree can be rescinded and that
should be a necessary part of so-called
forgiveness you didn't pay for it you
got to give it back
call it a refund instead of forgiveness
now i still wouldn't support even that
plan but it's at least a serious plan
and makes some attempt at being fair
but this is all academic pun intended
the feminists over at the women's march
aren't making a case for student loan
forgiveness they're making a case for
gender justice whatever that is only
because they didn't pay attention in any
of their math classes they don't realize
that the gender disparity on this issue
as with most other issues cuts in their
favor
so they're wrong about women being
specially victimized by student loans
and they're wrong about the student loan
issue in general they're wrong in every
way from every angle
other than that ladies great point also
you're cancelled
listen hit that subscribe button right
now do it right now i thank you for your
compliance it is
somewhat appreciated